la liberté éclairant le monde
non nous ne sommes pas à new york mais à
colmar il d'origine de bartleby le
sculpteur de la célèbre statue entre
ville et campagne le canton de colmar 1
s'étire des quartiers ouest de la ville
jusqu'aux vignes d'ingersheim
c'est là le premier arrêt de notre tour
sur le pont qui enjambe la fecht détruit
par un bombardement pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale ce pont qui relie les
deux parties du village furent
construits à la veille des années
cinquante et soixante six ans après donc
en 2015 conseil départemental du haut
rhin a décidé d'entamer une réflexion de
ce pont c'était même plus
qu'indispensable parce qu'au fur et à
mesure des travaux puisque les travaux
consistaient effectivement à revoir
l'étanchéité à consolider le pont à
refaire les trottoirs ainsi que la
balustrade et au fur et à mesure de
l'avancement des travaux ils ont
remarqué que l'acier qui se trouvait
dans le tablier du pont était rongé par
la corrosion et donc les travaux ont
duré quelques mois supplémentaires
puisqu'il fallait absolument encore une
fois refaire ce tablier
les travaux du pont donc on représente
grosso modo 380 mille euros entièrement
pris en charge par le conseil
départemental reste est à la charge de
la commune les balustrades effectivement
nous avons souhaité la municipalité a
souhaité conserver à l'identique les
balustrades dupont précédent
retour dans le centre-ville de colmar
nous sommes route de strasbourg un
désaxé les plus fréquentés de la cité et
si aujourd'hui les voitures s'arrêtent
au feu pour laisser passer les piétons
ce ne fut pas toujours le cas une
véritable plaie pour les riverains la
route de strasbourg est une voie
départementale en agglomération donc une
voix qui appartient au département en
ville de calme dans la ville de colmar
et c'est vrai que c'est une voix
toujours très difficile à traverser pour
les piétons et où la vitesse des
automobilistes étaient rapides c'est une
voie d'accès à la fois quand on vient du
nord de colmar et de strasbourg
c'est par là c'est une des entrées
principales dans la ville et c'est
également une des sorties principales
donc forcément c'est un axe très passant
qui est accidentogène et ça fait
plusieurs années qu'il y à une
discussion entre la ville et département
pour savoir qui fait quoi et ça
n'avançait pas tellement ce qui fait
avancer le dossier
et d'où l'intérêt finalement de cette
interface entre le fait que je sois
premier adjoint au maire de colmar et
conseiller départemental du canton c'est
justement qu'on a réussi à aboutir dans
le cas d'un conventionnement 50 50 entre
la ville de colmar et le département et
donc le montant de cet investissement
était de 100 mille euros et qui va se
partager la ville va payer 50% et le
département les 50 autres pour cent et
c'est ça qui a débloqué le sujet
rue de paris le collège molière c'est un
des trois établissements du canton
il accueille près de 500 élèves grande
nouvelle à la rentrée 2010 est une
section bilingue va ouvrir certains
élèves pourront alors poursuivre une
scolarité renforcer dans la langue de
goethe
la bonne nouvelle a été annoncée par le
rectorat de strasbourg courant mars 2016
c'est une forte demande depuis plusieurs
années et en face se voit concrétiser
l'aboutissement de leurs efforts pour
nous c'était très important de pouvoir y
développer et de faire ouvrir une
section bilingue
c'est à dire franck français et allemand
c'était un engagement qu'on avait pris
pendant la campagne électorale pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord parce que la
continuité de l'école primaire qui est
dans le quartier c'est le collège
molière qui aujourd'hui on est dépourvu
de sexus section bilingue
c'est une très grande demande des
parents parce que sur l'école primaire
qui est jouxte le collège qui est
l'école primaire fils terre une classe
bilingue est déjà en cours et donc là
les parents n'avaient plus la
possibilité pour leurs élèves leurs
enfants de continuer ce cursus et était
obligé de le mettre dans un institut
privé et ensuite et ça et l'expérience
va le montrer c'est l'un des tout
premiers collèges situés en zone urbaine
sensible en zone d'éducation prioritaire
zep qui va bénéficier de cette ouverture
d'une classe bilingue à colmar de le
faire dans une zone prioritaire c'est
encore plus important parce que du coup
en terme d'image pour le collège ça va
être un plus incontestable et ça va
permettre à ces élèves d'ouvrir de
nouveaux débouchés lorsqu'ils auront
compris l'importance de l'apprentissage
de la langue allemande
à deux pas de là au pied des tours ce
petit immeuble d'apparence modeste
c'est là à l'espace solidarité que les
habitants peuvent trouver l'ensemble des
services départementaux s'occupant des
politiques d'action sociale l'espace
solidarité c'est un centre de rencontre
deux d'école paria puisque c'est le
centre essentiel des gens qui rentrent
en problématiques familiales
intrafamiliales la petite enfance
jusqu'à la personne âgée donc ils sont
reçus ils sont écoutés ils sont soutenus
qu'ils sont accompagnés par du personnel
compétent
c'est un service de proximité on est
vraiment au coeur des villes et villages
des villes martin dietrich et moi même
nous sommes élus dans un canton
populaire c'est une partie de colmar en
l'occurrence colmar ouest où sont
concentrés la plupart des logements
sociaux de la ville c'est aussi dans ce
canton là quand on regarde la
composition du canton de les deux
cantons colmarien où il ya les revenus
les plus faibles
je crois que plus que jamais aujourd'hui
il faut pas confondre solidarité et
assistanat ceux des rites et ses hameaux
extrêmement important parce qu'il ya des
gens qui ponctuellement ou pour une
longue durée ont besoin d'un soutien de
la collectivité mais évidemment c'est
toujours de l'argent public
aujourd'hui l'argent public est rare
raison pour laquelle notre rôle de
politique c'est de le gérer au plus près
des chaque euro on part toujours du
principe que chaque euro investi doit
être un euro utile
la particularité du département et moi
j'y tiens particulièrement c'est pour ça
que je souhaitais être élu au
département
c'est justement la proximité et quand on
traite de problèmes sociaux quand on
traite de l'humain tout simplement la
proximité c'est quelque chose de
totalement indispensable un travail qui
est drôle de longue haleine et qui aime
et qui est intéressant et passionnant il
y avait des résultats